قصة رئيسية تتطور الآن في غزة،
ما تسميه الحكومة الفلسطينية
جريمة حرب، تقول الحكومة في
غزة إن قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
قصفت مستشفى في وسط
مدينة غزة، تقديرات أولية لمستشفى العلي المعمداني
من الحكومة في غزة
ولكن عدد القتلى  في الغارة التي وقعت في
مكان ما بين شخصين و300، نتوقع أن يكون
هناك العديد من الأبرياء الذين
ما زالوا محاصرين تحت الأنقاض، ويقول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إنه
يبحث في التقارير المتعلقة
بالحادث، ولا يزال من غير الواضح بالنسبة لهم
الآن ما إذا كان المستشفى قد
تعرض للقصف من قبل الحرب الإسرائيلية  طائرات أو بسبب
فشل إطلاق صاروخي من جانب حماس، دعنا ننتقل
مباشرة إلى كلاريسا وارد من شبكة سي إن إن الموجودة
في إسرائيل في بلدة أشالون
كلاريسا، نعم جيك، لقد سمعنا
صفارات الإنذار بدون توقف بشكل أساسي خلال
الساعات القليلة الماضية ردًا على هذه
الضربة المروعة على هذا
المستشفى المعمداني وهو مستشفى في مدينة غزة
يقع في الجزء الشمالي من
الجيب أه آلاف الأشخاص كانوا
يحتمون هناك من
العنف المستمر كثير من الناس يعالجون
هناك وبعضهم لا يمكن نقلهم
رغم أوامر الإخلاء التي صدرت
وكما ذكرت، فإننا
نسمع تقديرات أولية لمقتل ما لا يقل عن
2 إلى
300 شخص في تلك الغارة
والعديد من الأشخاص الآخرين الذين يخشى أن يكونوا قد لقوا حتفهم الآن،
وتصف حماس هذه بأنها إبادة جماعية، وقد
تعهدت حماس بالانتقام لها كما ذكرت
من قبل.  أرتدي الدرع الواقي من الرصاص مرة أخرى
لأننا شهدنا سلسلة من صفارات
الإنذار والصواريخ التي وصلت ليس
هنا فقط حيث أنا في أشالون ولكن في
أجزاء أخرى من إسرائيل أيضًا، ولكن بالتأكيد
تكثيف درامي ومروع
للعنف جيك عشية
الرئيس  زيارة بايدن هنا ليست واضحة إلى
أين يتجه هذا الأمر هنا، لقد ذكرت أن
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية قالت إنها تحقق في
الحادث، وأنه من المحتمل أن
يكون خطأً في إطلاق النار من جانب حماس، إذا كنت ترغب في إطلاق
صاروخ، فقد ألقينا نظرة على بعض
مقاطع الفيديو التي قمنا بها.  نحن لسنا مستعدين للمشاركة
عبر الإنترنت بعد ولكن من المؤكد أنه بدا وكأنه
انفجار هائل من الصعب أن نرى أه كيف كان
من الممكن أن يكون ذلك صاروخًا خاطئًا
ولكن بالتأكيد نحن ننتظر الحصول على
المزيد من CL في هذا الشأن وأه نخشى أن
يكون الأمر صعبًا جدًا  ليلة طويلة قادمة
مع المزيد من الصواريخ والمزيد من
العنف في أعقاب هذه
الضربة المروعة، حسنًا، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
كلاريسا.